des titres et des médailles est attendu
sur les championnats du monde d'escrimé
à moscou gros plan sur nos sabreuses
françaises vice-championnes d'europe
il y à un mois on n'a pas les quatre
meilleurs du monde à l'heure actuelle
par contre on a un cas de filles qui ont
un bon niveau donc ça c'est intéressant
sectionnistes ya un petit peu en dedans
balauze on peut espérer que ça marche
bien et puis à un soudaine normes et moi
je trouve très courageux dans ce cas
font comme un avantage une équipe de
france valeureuse avec c'est maintenant
une tradition plusieurs représentantes
orléanaise cécilia berder championne de
france en titre 26 ans bientôt et déjà
une grosse expérience internationale
qu'elle partage notamment avec manon
brunet sa partenaire de club on a
l'habitude de tirer ensemble on est une
vraie équipe aussi bien en club qu'en
équipe de france je sais exactement
comment manon réagi je sais exactement
en un regard si elle est bien si elle
est motivée si elle a peur donc voilà on
a un regard on arrive à communiquer
plein de choses donc évidemment qu'il ya
des feeder leur nom en équipe de france
je suis ravi parce que c'est plus rapide
c'est plus simple et voilà ça marche
bien entre nous elle beaucoup de
potentiel décelé chez manon brunet tout
juste 19 ans formé à orléans elle fait
son trou dans l'équipe de france senior
encore un petit pas à franchir pour
réussir à s'exprimer au plus haut niveau
comme ses aînés j'ai un petit peu mal à
gérer le stress cette année donc ça
c'est plus ou moins senti je sais pas si
c'est un manque de maturité ou peut être
un peu oui avec un peu de manque
d'expérience je pense à ça et dans le
froid aussi
donc j'essaye de voir - centrale comment
elles sont même de regarder comment les
filles avaient en face à nos meilleures
mondiales tiers comme ça je vais essayer
d'analyser beaucoup de choses mais moi
c'est quand même pas mal de choses à
apprendre
trop et même si les filles espèrent
briller en individuel c'est surtout à la
compétition par équipe qu'elle pense
marquer un maximum de points sur ces
championnats du monde pour s'ouvrir la
voie olympique